[Musique]
il porte le nom de bistro bar ou buvette
le café a toujours été un point de
rencontre qui n'est pas sans rappeler le
feu rhône antilles où chacun peut venir
aujourd'hui converser en consommant une
boisson nous laisserons le thé aux
anglais la bière aux habitants du haut
rhin
car la boisson nationale française reste
toujours le vin suivie des alcools le
free ou de plans ces poissons sont
aujourd'hui sévèrement réglementé aussi
avons-nous voulu savoir si la
physionomie du consommateur s'était
modifié depuis le début du siècle
monsieur porte vous êtes le maire d'une
petite commune rurale
combien d'habitants de cette commune 412
400 nos habitats votre métier vous amène
à sillonner la campagne
vous voyez la vie des paysans fin des
gens de la campagne connaît bien celle
là parce que je suis de cette date moi
même est ce qu'on boit beaucoup et la
campagne on me voit pas mal oui c'est
une distraction des campagnes quand on
sait la semble plusieurs le plaisir de
tank et qu'est ce qu'on boit du vin
rouge du rouge du pays et génèrent et
puis certainement des apéritifs dans le
champagne non émergents panne c'est trop
cher le champagne en format surtout du
bon vin rouge des alcools e de moins en
moins d'alcool eau-de-vie de moins en
moins la gnôle lannion en bretagne ou
non alors c'est en régression vraiment
moi je pense est en régression parce que
comparativement à ce que j'ai vécu
pendant bien 25 ou 30 ans au moins des
battages il on voit de moins en moins et
avaient des fermes
des scènes de matage où il se buvait de
2,4 litres d'eau-de-vie par jour ça
c'était fréquent je les ai vécus
attendant ça et maintenant on utilise de
moins en moins à quoi attribuez-vous ce
se passe là le genre de vie des gens qui
changent et les jeunes en consomment de
moins en moins les violettes
ils consomment dans wii le rouge et le
vin favori du paysan français qui reste
le meilleur client du cafetier les
jeunes et c'est heureux consomment
beaucoup moins dont une préférence pour
les apéritifs à base de plantes le
vermouth pour le médecin de campagne
sans rejeter les méfaits de l'alcoolisme
le verre de vin est avant tout un
symbole d'amitié un peu tu me de london
toi - fini - d'alcool enfin infiniment
moins d'autre vie que ceux qui se buvait
autrefois il n'y a pas eu et c'est le
problème
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de bord
il n'y a pas de mauvaises alcool dans le
fond à partir tant qu'on a à faire
l'alcool c'est à dire à l'alcool
éthylique tant qu'on n'a pas affaire à
des alcools vraiment frelaté comme j'en
ai rencontré par exemple pas malade hier
lorsque j'étais externe des hôpitaux de
marseille
en 43 nous avions nécessité total qui
étaient dus à l'alcool méthylique alors
que maintenant avec le cdh cenco h nous
en avions discuté tantôt on a quand même
des lésions moindre à la fin il n'y a
pas de bonnes alcool il n'y a pas de
mauvais alcool il ya qu une question de
quantité qu'une question de sobriété
mais la priver la question des
bouilleurs de cru mon dieu les jambes
trouveront toujours des alcools quelle
que soit l'origine je pense que les
bouilleurs de cru c'est une chose c'est
une survivance de vie tradition et je
brûle encore
je brûle encore en tant que bouilleurs
de cru parce que je veux conserver quand
même des droits qu'on nous autorise je
suis bouilleurs de cru et je
vous voulez que ça dure le plus
longtemps possible parce que moi aussi
j'aime bien ça je peux pas dire je ne
peux pas me faire incendier pas par des
confrères je ne peux pas de les défendre
et dire qu'il est nécessaire de les
conserver mais enfin je pense que là on
trouvera toujours dans l'alcool qu'ils
viennent des bouilleurs de cru ou des
fabricants danis le résultat sera le
même
alors vous êtes bouilleurs de cru mais
oui et l'autre vous exercer ce métier
depuis quarante quatre vous avez un
secteur important assez ou en bus et en
plus en plus d'eux étant donné que nous
diminuions le nombre de brouilleurs le
nom de goodyear et le nombre de clients
aussi le nombre de clients diminue aussi
maintenant d'ouvrir objections jeu
pendant longtemps j'ai une dizaine et
nous tous c'est un peu comme les battles
alors ben qu'est-ce que vous traitez
alors quand on a envie de tout l'est
celui tous les théories mais
principalement le raisin les marcs de
raisin nombre les sides now tous les
fruits
alors vous faites de l'alcool oui oui
quelle quantité faites-vous par client
le temps est bon aloi milieu gris qui
correspond à quoi sert ce litige se sont
intégrés par les franchises le degré
autorisé c'est combien alors aubenas il
n'y a pas de réautoriser non pas dire
maintenant 50 et 60 options se griller
ses sensations avec vos clients est ce
que vous constatez une diminution
de l'alcoolisme d'isolement ou chez les
jeunes par exemple et vous direz vous et
le pont franchement je n'ai plus le
jeune et je ne sais comme moi 50 ans
maintenant et vous savez ce ne sont pas
des alcooliques sont pas désactivable
votre vie et dans les familles à la
campagne il avait choisi commencent à
consommer les gens font du pineau et
même de fonder plus de fonds vers les
vins comme ça et d'une chanson beau et
j'en consomme surtout beaucoup pour les
bêtes ont fait part d'un nombre de
relais pour les sondés pictures il
fonder un tas de choses je connais des
gens qui consomment pas mal parce que la
totalité de leurs habitations
ils se servent comme antiseptique aussi
le bouilleur de cru est condamné à
disparaître un jour ce privilège
transmis uniquement de père en fils
appartient encore à quelques familles un
privilège que certains considèrent comme
un des principaux obstacles à la lutte
contre l'alcool et les vieux se faisait
vieux tout en buvant de l'alcool
et alors là je peux je peux si vous
voulez vous raconter une racontines
ancienne histoire il ya de cela 26e
cette annonce était du coup j'étais
arrivé je en dordogne et on m'avait
averti qu'il y avait un vin redoutable
qui se plaignent noah
c'était un vin blanc très éthéré je me
trouve un soir chez un vieux bonhomme
qui me demandent de da ros et ma
première visite
les gens sont très accueillants dans le
pays c'est peut-être un peu pour ça que
je suis resté périgourdin parce que sans
cela je serais peut-être retourner à
nice mais enfin le brave dieu m'offre du
vin blanc j'ai cru en me disant je lui
demandais ce qu'il dit noah là-dedans
bijoux garantie n'a pas un seul
gringoire tranquille et effectivement le
gave la moitié de son verre de vin
j'essaie de le goûter
c'est une effroyable alcool que l'on
appelle ici le brûle ou c'est-à-dire un
alcool qui devait être aux environs de
80 du brave homme qui avait 81 ans le
buvez appelés vers j'ai eu toutes les
peines du monde à m'en débarrasser en
l'envoyant dans la cheminée qui était
derrière moi j'ai failli faire mettre le
feu à la maison et le bonhomme tout
content de voir que j'avais vu son
alcool mal offert aussi c'est comme des
vers je suis arrivé à l'éviter mais lui
la vallée il avait 80 et quelques années
[Musique]